welcome to
[Music]
2024 to start this on a realistic
transparent
note I'm I'm struggling at the moment
and the reason for that is because I
have somehow fallen into a place where
where I seem to have two full-time jobs
and like a family to look after and I'm
also kind of a little bit homeless at
the moment not really but a little bit
so this two full-time job situation is
uh basically because I'm a YouTuber and
I make videos and I have to keep making
videos and I don't know how many of you
watching are YouTubers but like I don't
I don't think I think that's a very easy
job depends on what you're doing I guess
but I would I would not say being like
making YouTube videos full time is is an
easy job you know I think I like I
worked full-time at EA and then I left
and like to make YouTube videos
full-time and I think that was like that
was not a transition where I was like oh
sweet I've got so much free time now
this is this is amazing but then like
I'm also you know building a game engine
that's not easy either and like you know
I you know we the team we have big plans
for hazel so it's not something that I
can treat lightly you know Peter works
on Hazel all the way in Sweden it that's
his job like that's that's his only job
that's what he does for a living there
are volunteers also we have zerox or Jim
we have Emily we have Jay we are
building this you know substantially
compx Le Lex product of which I am the
director of but like not just from a
product directional Vision standpoint
from like a software engineering
technical leadership standpoint and
drawing this back to the fact that you
know game engines are complicated and
they're not very easy to build you know
if we're a small team then building such
a a mammoth of a piece of software ain't
easy It Ain't Easy bro so this video is
going to go in in one of two directions
either I just resign right now and say
that's it it is it's finished it's done
there is no more Cho on the Internet or
you and I figure out a way to try and
combine these
two jobs of mine now the the thing is
like like I've tried this before like if
you think that this is my first time
being like you know let's like oh why
don't I think making videos about hazel
it's so easy I see so many YouTubers
making devlogs about games and that's
all their channel is and I think to
myself like yeah those Dev Vlogs are
definitely taking up a a decent amount
of time to produce but at least all of
their videos are basically centered
around their major project that they're
working on now my videos are a little
bit different you know my channel is is
there's a a a diverse amount of content
there's there's variety it's not just
Hazel 24/7 it's code reviews it's like
C++ videos which I haven't done in a
while it's tutorial style content like
how do we use I'm goey to do this or
that or like what's the best way to like
read the C++ code I definitely don't
want to stop making helpful videos
because people seem to benefit from that
and people seem to enjoy that and also
they usually do well like views wise and
that's important because that's how I
support my existence and not even just
my existence but I think that everyone
can probably agree looking at my channel
if you really critically analyze my
channel I don't know if anyone thinks
about this but I feel like I'm just not
very good at making devlogs I feel like
I just for whatever reason I can't keep
doing it I don't like the way they turn
out I think they're boring it's really
weird because you know I like telling
stories I like showing things I wanted
to be a filmmaker before I actually got
into programming in the first place and
yet making the development of a 3D game
engine with a team of talented people
just seems to be
impossible I don't know why so as we sit
here in this new office that still needs
a lot of work done to it which I'm going
to do I'm going to try again I'm going
to it's 2024 you knew where this was
going as I said it's either I resign or
I try again I'm going to try and make
interesting videos showing my life and
the development of Hazel this is this is
the dev vog like version 20 the truth is
that like because I've been so busy
making other videos and because of lots
of other stuff going on in my life which
I may share in later videos I've been
almost solely focused on making YouTube
videos that are not related to Hazel and
my only real involvement with hazel has
been directing the team having meetings
with the team seeing what people are
working on seeing what they need help
with giving technical advice and
guidance fixing maybe the occasional bug
if I'm lucky and that's not enough like
I need to work on Hazel I need to it
started off as my engine I was the only
one who did anything on it and now it's
grown and there as a team doing it and
because of that it keeps moving forward
but it's like it's moving forward
without me because I don't have time to
do it anymore because I'm so busy making
other videos whereas I really feel like
I'm tipping too too too much into that
into that kind of place because there
needs to be a balance there a scale of
Cho the software engineer and chno the
the the YouTuber and if I'm doing too
much programming not off videos like I
feel like you know Financial incentives
aside like I feel like I want to make
more videos if I'm making too many
videos I feel like I want to be
programming I want to be working on
Hazel I want to be actually building
something not just talking about
building something like I am right now
it's kind of therapeutic this video
recording experience for me anyway I
actually had a pretty decent
week I had a bad week spent the evening
pretending it wasn't that deep maybe
later um you know let's go over my week
what what day it's Thursday the 18th of
January today I did three live streams
this week can I just talk about how like
happy I am with myself for doing that so
so the first live stream on Monday
Monday night was kind of like a a bit of
a test live stream because that was my
my first live stream in the office and
it was my return to Twitch as well so
for those of you who don't know I left
twitch uh and moved to YouTube live
streaming full-time I guess on the Cho
unplugged Channel which I'll have linked
below that's like my long form content
SL livestream Channel I did that because
I was really mostly live streaming the
game engine series and I had to like
edit that put that up on YouTube anyway
and I was like why don't I stream it
directly to YouTube the quality will be
better as well cuz twitch limits you to
6 megabits a second people joining late
can rewind the live stream the the VOD
like the video stays up on YouTube after
the stream is done automatically it just
made a lot of sense but then I was kind
of missing the spontaneous live
streaming aspect if I have an hour and I
I need to do some programming why not
just Chuck a stream up that kind of
behavior I was missing a little bit
because I was like well it's on YouTube
like you know do I save the VOD do I not
save the VOD it felt a little bit more
official it almost felt like it had to
be higher quality because like I don't
know I don't have a good reason why it
did but I just I really felt like since
twitch and YouTube both allow this in
their live streaming agreements like why
don't I just treat twitch as like the
live streaming platform and YouTube as
the video platform but then the game
engine series which remember is at the
end of the day just video content it's
episodic video content but it's recorded
live it's streamed live so that makes
sense for that to be on YouTube because
the the whole purpose of that stream is
to produce a video and then that way for
Content that was purely supposed to be a
live stream first and foremost like that
would be on Twitch and I you know I
missed all the other twitch features you
know that were missing from YouTube live
streaming so it was kind of nice to be
back so I did that on Monday then
Tuesday game engine series then
Wednesday I in the morning I was just
like the stuff that I've been working on
in Hazel is bugging me a little bit let
me share it with you and so I
I did a live stream in fact why don't I
just show you what it was that was
bugging me I'm just going to show you
I'm just going to show you like on the
computer I was going to edit the live
stream that I recorded and just show you
bits and pieces of the like what the
process was like what was bugging me
those live streams were like a
collective 4 hours I just like I'm I'm
going to be real here I just don't have
time to go through that much footage and
edit it if I had an
editor maybe that would be better
instead what I want to do is like
provide you with like a dramatic
reenactment of uh what was going on what
I'm working on and like how I fixed some
of the things that were bugging me so
what you're seeing here is Hazel a very
bright Hazel uh and that's actually part
of the problem we get to that in a
minute and what I was working on was I
was finally getting around to finishing
thumbnails because one of the one of the
big things for this year I really should
one of the things is we're kind of
making the editor a little bit better
and so part of that is thumbnails so you
can see that like before we just had
icons like this for everything
what I have been working on what I
started working on about a year ago for
a week then I abandoned it now I'm
coming back to it is thumbnails so you
can see this is a texture for example
this is a mesh Source we're able to
actually see these things you know in
the form of like a preview thumbnail
that shows what they are and this works
not just for things like textures but
also for mashes and it also works for
materials and so what I was seeing was
this like check out this weird like
spotty I don't even know what's going on
it's just it doesn't it looks really
really weird and you know if you look at
the actual uh material over here there's
no albo map I think there is in this one
right but there's no albo map in here so
it's not like it's part of the texture
of that material no for some reason it
is just it's just weird like these
artifacts but furthermore you can see
that these these materials don't have
that so there's very something very
specific going on with this material
that's not in this material that's
causing this problem but there's also as
you may have noticed there's just a lot
of brightness going on like even if I go
to meshes like look at this let me just
make this
bigger look at this Cube
scene why is it
glowing there's a lot of light there's a
lot of light energy coming from
somewhere now how do I debug where this
is coming from well these thumbnails
these ones over here uh the code that
controls how that's working is this
material thumbnail generator and so what
it does is it sets up a Hazel scene you
know assigns the material to a sphere
renders it and the lighting is
associated with this is a directional
light as well as the standard lighting
that we use for every single scene that
we render so like those meshes that were
also ended in the scene like the mesh
thumbnails I mean all of that has an
environment light called a skylight so
these things are all flowing through
Hazel's just standard like physically
based rendering shaders and so the cool
thing about that is check this out we
can just edit those shaders and
regenerate the thumbnails so if I open
up the PBR Shader for example and this
is exactly what I did on stream in fact
I haven't actually I haven't actually
reverted it this is what it used to be
if I go over here into shaders and I
reload this Shader this is actually what
it's supposed to be like with like a
directional light but anyway the point
is I can edit this Shader code that is
rendering both the scene and these
thumbnails so if I set it to Pink for
example I reload this Shader we're
obviously going to see it in the scene
but then if I press this little button I
made to clear the thumbnail cache and
regenerate the thumbnails you can see
that that they're pink so this is
fantastic because I've now got obviously
a very easy way to sort of debug the
rendering that's going into all of these
thumbnails and so you can see that it's
very easy to first of all discern
whether or not the problem is coming
from direct lighting such as this
directional light that we see here
there's like you know Point lights and
stuff and spotlights in the scene but in
the scene for these thumbnails there's
just a directional light so we have that
directional light clearly looks pretty
good like no spots nothing like that so
it's definitely going to be with the
image based lighting which is kind of
our indirect environment light and you
can see that over here so that's good so
let's kind of scroll up and take a look
at the code that's doing that's
calculating that lighting and we see it
over here so image based lighting is
made up of two components really there's
the diffuse and there's the specular if
you're a graphics person this is
probably already clicking because you
may have noticed from earlier that these
don't have the
spots right so what's the difference
between this and this well the these
clearly look like Metals so the way that
metals are rendered is they actually
don't have this diffuse component
there's this term called KD over here
I'm not going to get too deep into this
but the point is this you can see that
there's a parameter for the metalness
for whether or not this material is a
metal or a dialectric so dialectric like
a plastic or wood something like that so
if it is a metal then this would be one
and 1 - one is zero and anything time 0
is z so this KD is z and 0 * diffuse IBL
means that term obviously gets canceled
out entirely so just the specular I is
being used for these metals and if I
reload the Shader and then regenerate
these thumbnails you can see they have
no effect and obviously all of these now
look like Metals so we know that the
problem has to be inside this diffuse
IBL and if we do look at that
specifically then you can see now
everything is basically using that the
metals are all black because this is
zero but if we narrow this down more
diffuse IBL really I mean the albo gets
multiplied with the radians but the
Radiance is just this irradiance texture
which is like a 32x32 cube map that
contains an extremely blurry
representation of our environment map so
if I quickly show you roughly what that
would look like if I go into the
Skylight that we have for this which is
actually what's creating this backdrop
and I just change this L to like I don't
know this or something it's very bright
but this is what you're looking at now
is basically what the radiance map would
look like so it's a very very low
resolution 32x32 very blurry
representation of the environment like
it's so blurry that it can act as like
the diffus component meaning it's just
like the pure very simplified light
colors and energy amount of energy as
well that's that's hitting your object
if we go back over here this line over
here you can see samples that irradiance
texture that Cube map based on the
normals of the object you're rendering
that's being used as a texture
coordinate so if I just look at that
irradiance and I reload this then well
there we go so this is just the
environment map not multipli by by the
albo that's why you don't see the colors
anymore and it's obviously got these
weird spots it was at this point that I
remembered I know what this is I fixed
this problem and I'm pretty sure I fixed
it more than once in Hazel I don't know
why it's present but it is and by the
way the other thing that I did was you
can see I verified to make sure that it
was in fact happening in this viewport
in the scene as well just to make sure
there wasn't something really weird with
the scene setup for these thumbnails so
this is like the main scene and you can
see it's still it's still got that so
with that in mind we know that the
radiance texture is messed up for some
reason so how does the radiance texture
get generated issue is probably going to
be there and if we take a look at the
radiance texture and how it gets
generated well as I mentioned it's a
32x32 like resolution Cube map per face
and that's obviously quite a low
resolution compared to this the original
Source environment map which is probably
like going to be a 2048 or like a 4K
resolution Cube map like this is much
smaller so how do we down sample all of
that data like 4,096 by 496 you know
that's a lot of data that's a lot of
pixels how do we down sample that into
something so small whilst still
retaining an accurate representation of
the general light that's happening in
that environment and the answer is we
sample the hell out of it so you can see
there's a uniform here called samples
and samples is multiplied by 64 to
create this variable and this variable
is the for Loop iteration count so 64 *
samples now samples are defined inside
the renderer config and they are set to
IR Radiance map compute samples
512 so 512 *
64 which is
32,000 this runs 32,000 times but
wait per
pixel
so for each pixel of the irradiance cube
map this we basically kind of average is
32,000 samples of the original Source
asset so what does that mean and why is
it relevant to the spotting well to cut
a long story short since we are really
considering that Source asset so heavily
if you have parts of that environment
map that just contain too much light
energy then because those values are so
wildly High you kind of begin to see the
sampling pattern inside your what should
be a completely diffuse very cleanly
buttery smooth sampled Radiance map and
that's really easy to test so This Is Us
sampling the original Radiance map which
is that full resolution Cube map that we
use for the specular component of our
image based lighting we're sampling that
over here let's just maybe set this to
like well let's cap it at a max value so
we're going to set it to to be no higher
than like let's say 500 that's what I
used on the Stream So if I now run this
because remember the other issue that I
was seeing that I was noticing in the
back of my mind was just the excessive
brightness of everything so this is
beginning to make sense but really the
reason why I came on to this I think so
quickly is just because I had done I had
done it before and I think that as you
as you get more experience you know
working with graphics and rendering you
Vis like you you just develop an eye for
these things you visually begin to see
like oh I can see like the math being
wrong in this part or in that part
because because I guess what you're
seeing like final image like what you
are seeing or every step of the way what
you're seeing is just the result of math
and certain miscalculations certain
common mistakes tend to look a
particular way so now if I look at this
this is the exact same scene you can see
this is way darker now but also we don't
have that anymore right this looks much
better now at this point in time and I
guess we should probably look at the
actual thumbnails but you can see that
it's also gone from here like these look
pretty nice now these look pretty smooth
so at this point of course what we would
do is we would go back to the Shader and
we'd be like all right well let's get
back our KD * diffuse IBL plus specular
IBL so we're getting back that term so
we're adding in that specular now which
would show up for metallic materials so
if I reload this oh this is super bright
again and if I regenerate the thumbnails
they look they look pretty good I think
not too bad but there's still like this
weird section like look at this guy
doesn't this guy look super weird he's
like dark in the middle kind of like
half a moon and and then he's like
really like it almost looks like the Fel
is just crazy and then this is just it
just looks really weird and of course it
probably doesn't take a genius at this
point to realize that well obviously the
way that we did it just then was we only
did it affecting the radiance so this
was sampling the already hugely bright
Radiance map so the solution should be
when we initially read that and we read
these from Echo rectangular
uh 2D images why don't we just do that
capping here so let's grab the color
that we sample from the original Echo
rectangular texture and let's just make
sure that there is some kind of Maximum
in place now if I was doing this more
formally this might be a definition this
might be like potentially even some
uniform variable or something that might
be controllable just because I feel like
maybe sometimes you are going for a
weird effect or you want to control this
or 500 might even be too much for your
taste maybe you want to cap it to 50 so
there is probably you know future work
there to improve it and of course if you
add it here you don't need to have it
inside the radiance anymore let's also
make sure we're making this a 4 cuz it's
a 4 here and setting this to color and
there we go this is our scene now so
this is the exact same scene that you
just saw but now we're capping both like
the radiance and the IR Radiance map so
if I take a look at our thumbnails
notice how much darker everything is by
the way let me just make these guys
bigger so yeah they look much better now
uh this still has that sort of behavior
but you can see it looks much better
like the Fel isn't crazy this is just I
think way more how it's supposed to be
compared to what it was before here's
that Cube
scene totally not too bright anymore in
fact you can probably turn off that
Skylight by the way one thing that we're
still not doing is direct lighting
because I didn't have that so if we go
back to the PBR Shader let's bring back
light contribution plus I contribution
light contribution really is just direct
lighting contribution into the uh final
color of that pixel so if we reload um
the PBR Shader we should see it
obviously now all the direct lighting
like the spotlights and everything is
back now and then if I refresh this you
can see this looks a bit brighter
because it's got direct lighting and if
we go into a place with more uh you know
we've even got shadows and stuff which
is pretty cool inside these thumbnails
pretty nice pretty good quality
thumbnails um then uh yeah like if we go
back to those materials cuz I think they
they may have also had a directional
light yeah so you can see that kind of
Shadow or the the darker spot really
it's not really a shadow but it's almost
like a self Shadow that's part of the um
directional light that's in the scene
and yeah so that's our nice thumbnails
so that's one of the things that was
bugging me that I really wanted to fix
so I just jumped up on a live stream and
fixed it I think the dramatic
reenactment way of explaining this
instead of editing together a live
stream of it happening in real life it's
kind of nice to be honest because I
think it's a lot quicker uh it lets me
reflect on it and also it hopefully
encourages you to watch the live stream
cuz you're not going to get that content
anywhere else so uh twitch.tv/ the chano
I'm going to get a coffee and I'm going
to film it for the Vlog how does this
look I've Never filmed a video on my
car it's kind of fun being a vlogger I
don't have like a um I don't have a
stand like a how's this angle it's
probably complete
rubbish you see meal record all
right I'm just going to like order a
cappuccino and then collect the
cappuccino and then drive back
so I don't know maybe I don't need to
film
this and we're back in the office yet
another successful coffee
run Tesla coffee